so cory bush is this radical missouri
congress person
she got her start being a black lives
matter activist and then she's become
this very loud adjunct member of the
squad
she's the second wave member of the
squad the squad existed and then she was
recently
elected to congress was corey bush and
of course she made headlines this week
when she camped out on the steps of the
capitol building to
protest evictions and then the biden
administration announced
that in defiance of the constitution of
the united states joe biden would simply
declare
an eviction moratorium even if it would
be struck down by the supreme
court itself and here's the thing why
would you follow corey
bush down this primrose path at all cory
bush is terrible her policies are not in
line with what the vast majority of
americans want
the entire democratic party has spent
the last few months attempting for
example
to run ahead long away from the defund
the police sloganeering
of people like corey bush and aoc and
nohan omar and rashida talib
and yet when it comes to much of their
policy they seem to be following the
lead
of the squad and every so often corey
bush will just leroy jenkins it
right every so often the democratic
probably like guys we really we don't
need to do this defund the police stuff
because it's really it pulls really bad
you know let's do let's do this policy
stuff in the dead of night when not a
lot of people are watching but let's not
campaign
as overtly radical let's not do that and
then corey bush will be like leroy
jenkins and just
rush in you know face first so that's
what happened
yesterday corey bush was doing an
interview and she declared
that she wanted to defund the police but
she didn't just say that she said i pay
for security
i have taxpayer-funded security i need
security but you
the regular people you don't need police
we should defund the police
i'm going to make sure i have security
because i know i have had attempts on my
life
and i have too much work to do there are
too many people that need help right now
for me to allow that so if i end up
spending 200
000 if i spend 10 10 10 more dollars on
it
you know what i get to be here to do the
work so
suck it up and defunding the police has
to happen we
need to defund the police and put that
money into social safety nets
because we're trying to save lives so in
the exact same sentence where she says
that she deserves 200
000 of security she says that you should
not have security
why are the democrats following this and
here's the thing i think the reason that
the democrats have decided that they're
going to treat the squad and the radical
left of their own party with respect
is not really for electoral benefit so
much as it
is about the belief by the democrats
that anytime somebody on the right has a
critique
the critique has to be false there's a
really interesting piece today
over at a substance called the liberal
patriot by a guy named roy teshera now
roy teshera is a major democrat
and roy teshera is one of the people who
used to write essays about the browning
of america and how demographic change
was eventually going to lead
to this magical democratic utopia
well now he is warning that democrats
are completely disconnected from reality
that they have fallen into what he calls
the fox news fallacy here's what he says
he says the fox news fallacy
is having a dire effect on many
democrats this is the idea that if fox
news
substitute here the conservative bet
noir of your choice if you prefer
criticizes the democrats for x
there must be absolutely nothing to x
and the job of democrats is to assert
that
loudly and often the problem is that an
issue is not necessarily completely
invalid just because fox news mentions
it
that depends on the issue if there's
something to the issue and persuadable
voters have real concerns
you will not allay those concerns by
embracing the fox news fallacy in fact
you'll probably intensify them by giving
such voters the impression that
democrats simply don't care about their
concerns
and will do nothing to address them that
will undermine the democrats ability to
respond
to predictable attacks against their
candidates in 2022 and
raise the likelihood of a midterm
debacle and he
cites a few examples of this one of them
is crime he points out that a lot of
people on the right have been pointing
out the rising crime rates in major
cities around the united states and yet
democrats
continue to proclaim over and over and
over again that there really is no big
crime problem
that the crime problem is all just made
up by the fox news crowd
and this is not going to redound to the
democrats benefit
another example of what reuters calls
the fox news fallacy
is the immigration issue he says the
biden administration has resisted
and still resists calling the situation
at the mexican border a crisis and
initially insisted that the surge at the
border would go away on its own
as the hot weather season arrived this
was the line most democrats adhered to
invoking the idea
the issue was more a fox news talking
point than a real problem
it's now apparent the border search is
not going away anytime soon and that the
perceived liberalization of the border
regime under the biden administration
has indeed spurred more migrants to try
their luck at the border and it's not
going away
with the hot weather the washington post
reports officials have made
more than one million apprehensions at
the southwest border this fiscal year as
of june
210 000 more individuals probably
crossed in july
this is the highest monthly encounter
number since fiscal year 2000.
and there's a reason why joe biden's
approval rating on immigration is now at
37 up 52 down
he is only at 30 approval rating among
independents by the way
and critical race theory is another
issue where democrats are completely
missing the vote
because republicans mention it democrats
have decided that this is no longer
worth concerning themselves over
there's almost a sort of bizarre
it's it's like a bizarre reverse
psychology effect here that democrats
are falling prey to
the minute that republicans say
something is a problem democrats
immediately declare
that not only is it not a problem it's
something good so if we say
that the squad is completely radical and
proposing policies that are ridiculous
on their face
the democrats say that we're making it
up and then the american people know
we're not making it up because
they have eyes they have ears they can
see it happening by the way this also
happens in reverse
right this is not unique to the to the
left the right has this as well
if the left makes a criticism of the
right that has some legitimacy to it
very often people on the right will just
go well if the left is saying it must be
false
well no it might be false but that
doesn't mean it definitely is false
right now for the biden administration
however they are falling into a real
political trap here because they are so
attached to the idea
that fox news is the font of all evil
and shows like this one are not worth
listening to
and that anyone who disagrees with them
is a vicious bigot they're so attached
to that idea
that they are disregarding the fact that
many many americans agree that their
agenda has skewed far too radical
and as roy sharer points out this is
certainly true with regard to critical
race theory
right the the american people do not
like critical race theory
the the polling data shows this stuff is
really really unpopular it's unpopular
in virginia
and roy teshera concludes democrats who
embrace the fox news fallacy are
inclined to believe there is no real
issue here other than voters whipped up
by fox news who are simply opposed to
teaching students about slavery and the
like
that is a mistake and blinds democrats
to a real problem that is emerging
generally democrats need to wean
themselves away from the fox news
fallacy as a generic response
to conservative attacks this is exactly
correct but democrats don't seem to be
getting the message
now with regard to the corey bush wing
of the democratic party and now with
regard to coveter because it turns out
that a lot of the critiques from the
right
are steeped not in anti-vaxxerism
they are steeped in data they are
steeped in science
they're pointing out that there is a
serious lack of data for much of what
the left is calling for
right now and because the left doesn't
like the right they're just ignoring it
and they're pretending
that they can dismiss all of that with
the wave of a hand and everybody will
just accept it this is a bad political
move for them i mean honestly if they
want to do it
go for it it's just gonna make a lot of
lives worse and then they're just gonna
get the ass kicking they deserve come
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content